Hello, my name is Jay Judkowitz.
I'm the product manager for
Google Cloud Platform block
storage products.
I'm here with some
news, technical details,
and best practices
about block storage
in Google Cloud Platform.
At Google, we're always excited
to bring new storage offerings
to the cloud.
That's because it's all based
on the great technology we've
built in-house to run some of
the largest and most successful
applications on the internet.
When you use Google
Cloud, you're
taking advantage of the same
great storage infrastructure
as we do at Google.
Block storage in the cloud
is general-purpose storage
that you attach to a
virtual machine that
appears as a disk
drive to the VM.
You generally format it
with some file system
and write files or
databases to it.
It's what you use to create your
own self-managed data stores.
This section will announce
two new pieces of news
about block storage
in Google Cloud,
and quickly describe the
three block storage options
that we now have.
Cloud Platform offers three
types of block storage.
The key difference
between them is how many
I/Os per second, or
IOPS, can be supplied
by each gigabyte of storage.
Higher IOPS per
gigabyte trade off
against cost and flexibility.
The first option, Standard
Persistent Disk, or PD,
has been around
since Google Compute
Engine was first released.
It utilizes networked
hard drives.
It's designed for security,
high availability,
and consistent performance.
For use cases that
need up to, say, two
random read IOPS per second per
gigabyte, this option is ideal.
You get steady performance
at a low price.
The second option,
SSD Persistent Disk,
we're pleased to announce is
in general availability now.
It's like Standard PD,
but backed by network SSD.
As a result, you
have a higher cost
but a higher performance
per gigabyte.
Use it like you would Standard
PD, but in cases where you need
between two and 30 IOPS per gig.
The third option is not
generally available,
but is now accepting
trusted testers.
It's a local SSD option.
It offers the highest
possible performance,
but has availability,
durability, and flexibility
trade-offs I'll discuss shortly.
Before we get too
deep into the numbers,
let's give a quick overview
of the similarities
and differences between the
two PD options, and local SSD.
First, the similarities.
All of our block
storage options are
priced on a per-gigabyte basis,
with no I/O charges ever.
This makes planning simpler,
and eliminates surprises.
All of our block
storage options are
designed to perform
consistently.
Consistently between
similar volumes,
and consistently over time.
Third, all of our block storage
options are encrypted on disk.
And because PD is a
network storage offering,
the data is also
encrypted over the wire.
This is to give you the
best possible security.
Lastly, all of our block storage
options support live migration,
and are therefore not affected
by planned downtimes that
keep Google Cloud data centers
patched and maintained--
which is what keeps
your applications as
secure and available
as possible.
Now for differences.
Starting with reliability.
PD has additional
reliability that
comes from storing
its data redundant,
so the volumes can survive
the sudden loss of hardware.
Local SSD does not
have this redundancy.
It's up to you to
protect the data that
needs to survive
storage failures.
PD also was built in check sums.
Whenever you read
data, no matter
how long ago it was
stored, PD makes sure
that it returns what
was written to you,
and avoids silent
data corruptions.
Lastly, PD has a
snapshot functionality
that makes it easier for you to
protect your data against user
error and physical disasters.
In terms of performance,
while all the
block storage options
perform consistently,
local SSD has much
higher IOPS, and is
designed for
sub-millisecond latency,
making it ideal for the most
performance-hungry databases.
For flexibility, note
that both PD and local SSD
are very flexible.
PD volumes are
the more flexible,
in that they can be created
in sizes ranging from as small
as one gigabyte all the
way up to 10 terabytes,
in one-gigabyte increments.
And it could be attached and
detached from VMs on the fly.
Local SSD, by contrast,
can be allocated
to VMs only at creation
time, and needs
to be allocated in one to four
partitions of 375 gigabytes.
While this isn't
as flexible as PD,
local SSD does not require
special instance types
with pre-specified
amounts of SSD.
This lets you right-size the
VM, CPU, memory, and storage.
So given these
three options, how
do you decide which option is
right for your application?
Let's split it up by use case.
First, boot volumes
and bulk storage
are great use cases
for standard PD,
because those use cases require
low IOPS and low throughput,
and basically just
want to occupy
the cheapest reliable
space available.
Streaming I/O is a use case
that works best for Standard PD
as well.
While the other two options
have a much lower cost per IOPS,
the cost per throughput
is generally better
on Standard PD.
Reading large, sequential blocks
is what disks are good at.
SQL databases, like MySQL and
Postgres, and NoSQL databases,
like Cassandra,
Mongo, and Redis,
tend to be transactional
and IOPS-heavy.
Smaller instances might be
able to be run on Standard PD,
but important production
databases should usually
be run on some form of
SSD-- either SSD Persistent
Disk, or local SSD, depending
on how high the IOPS needs are.
File servers, like
NFS Gluster or Ceph,
can be more streaming
or more transactional,
depending on what the
clients are doing.
SSD PD is generally
a great choice here.
High performance scratch disk,
where keeping the track glocal
is the right architecture,
should go on local SSD.
For Hadoop deployments,
where I/O needs
exceed what Google Cloud
Storage Connector for Hadoop
can provide-- for that case,
you should use local SSD,
under Hadoop
Optimized File System.
Here's another way to
visualize the same information.
As you can see, depending on
the performance needs of file
servers or databases,
you have options
as to which block
storage product to use.
To decide, you'll
want to get down
to the real numbers
of space and IOPS.
I'll go through some specific
examples just a bit later
in the presentation.
But right now, let's
double-click on Persistent
Disk, and talk about
what separates the two PD
options-- their performance.
With both options,
Standard and SSD,
for both read and
write, the more space
you buy, more IOPS you get.
But SSD Persistent Disk grows
in IOPS capability much faster
than Standard PD, which
is why it costs more.
Each gigabyte of SSD PD
gets 20 times the write IOPS
of a gigabyte of
Standard PD, and a hundre
times the read IOPS of a
gigabyte of Standard PD.
These high IOPS
numbers are what make
SSD PD ideal for
transactional workloads,
like heavily used databases.
Now, the SSD PD
IOPS grow so fast
that they reach the
limit of the IOPS
that a VM can handle at
a relatively low volume
size, which is why
these graphs have
this plateau at the
top of the IOPS curve.
We're always working to
increase the per VM limits,
and you should check on
the current documentation
for the latest numbers, rather
than coming back the graph.
Moving from IOPS to
throughput, same pattern here.
Performance grows with
space for both options.
Unlike the IOPS
grass, however, you
can see that SSD PD's advantage
in throughput is less dramatic.
And both Standard and SSD PD
can hit the VM throughput limits
at moderate sizes.
This explains why we
recommend Standard PD
for throughput-oriented
applications
that have low IOPS.
While SSD PD has a much
better cost per IOPS,
Standard PD has the better
cost for throughput.
Like with the
previous slide, please
check the latest
documentation, as we're always
striving to raise the per
VM caps on throughput,
just like with IOPS.
The idea of growing IOPS
with space is pretty unique,
and many customers have asked
us why we designed it this way.
We made this choice because
of the following benefits
that we think are
very important.
First, simple and
consistent pricing.
With this model, there's
no billing variations
due to your app's I/O
needs changing over time.
The cost of a volume
is the same from month
to month with no surprises,
because all the I/O
was included in the
cost of the space.
Second, consistency
of performance.
This is critical.
By selling I/O and space
together in a safe ratio,
we stabilize the
overall storage traffic,
and keep volume performance
consistent over time.
This means your app won't suffer
the noisy neighbor problem.
Third, simplicity of in-VM
management and snapshot
management.
Because larger volumes
give you the performance
of many small volumes, your
spared the upfront effort
of striping volumes together.
And because each VM needs
only one data volume,
management of snapshots
becomes trivial.
Each volume snapshot is a
copy of an entire VM's data
at a given time.
Lastly, we wanted to give you
consistency across the product
line.
We've been able to make
all three block storage
options behave similarly.
You don't need to pick between
different price and performance
models, or plan I/O down to
the individual IOPS level.
We've tried to simplify
everything as much as possible.
You decide how much
space you need,
and you pick the storage type
based on how many IOPS per gig
need to come along with it.
Now at this point,
I'd like to help you
with the most important
decisions you're
going to make in
implementing block storage.
Given the three
options, how do you
decide which to
use for which app,
and how large do you need
to make the volumes in order
to get the performance you need?
While I can't give you an
exhaustive process or algorithm
to answer all the
use cases, I will
walk through four
separate examples
to show you how you can
approach to decision
for your application.
In the first
example, we're going
to have 300 gigabytes of space,
and a fairly modest amount
of I/O. 60 random reads
per second, and 120
random writes per second.
Here, simply 350 gigabytes
of Standard Persistent Disk
will do the trick nicely.
Very economical cost, and
give you all the I/O you need,
with some to spare.
The second example is
actually the trickiest one.
Here, we're still going to go
with 350 gigabytes of space,
but this time with more I/O.
450 random reads per second,
and 600 random
writes per second.
We can quickly see that 350
gigabytes of Standard PD
will not give a sufficient
I/O. While we could move up
to Standard PD, SSD PD, we
don't absolutely need to.
Because the price of
Standard PD is so low,
we can actually create roughly
an 1800-gigabyte Standard PD
volume, and it winds up
meeting the performance needs
while still being somewhat
more cost-effective
than a 350-gigabyte
SSD PD volume would be.
The third example leaves
us no room for doubt.
Here, we want 350
gigabytes of space,
and a large amount of
I/O. 9,000 randon IOPS.
Here, 300 gigabytes of SSD
PD meets the needs perfectly.
In the last example,
we're going to stay
with 350 gigabytes of space, but
this time, a very large amount
of I/O. We're going to go
for 60,000 random IOPS.
Here, you can use a single
local SSD partition of the four
that you could use.
A single partition will meet
both the space and the IOPS
requirements.
So now let's switch over
to general best practices,
focusing on
Persistent Disk here.
Most of the best practices
we're going to talk about
are about performance.
The first performance
tip comes from the fact
that PD works with
four-kilobyte I/O boundaries.
Any misaligned I/O
will dramatically
lower the performance.
All of the PD I/O should be
multiples of four kilobyte,
and aligned to
four-kilobyte boundaries.
Disk partitions and
their file systems
must be aligned to
those 4K boundaries.
The easiest way to
be sure of doing this
properly is to have a
simple partitioning scheme,
with a single partition
for the volume,
and to format that partition
using the Google-provided Safe
Format and Mount script.
The operating system
and application stack
should do everything
else for you.
Here's a syntax for that
Safe Format and Mount script.
And keep in mind, if you
don't use that script,
and you format your file
systems on your own,
please make sure to
align on 4K boundaries.
And if you mount your
file systems on your own,
please make sure to mount
with the Discard option.
The Discard option makes
format times much faster,
makes snapshots
smaller, faster to take,
and makes storing those
snapshots less expensive.
The next performance
recommendation
is about tuning your application
properly for your I/O pattern.
Starting with IOPS.
PD attains its high
IOPS performance
through the use of
parallelism on the back end.
Therefore, for higher IOPS, you
may need a larger queue depth,
or application thread pool.
The more I/Os you
can issue at once,
the faster the PD volumes
can return the data.
You'll need a queue depth of
one for every 400 to 800 IOPS
you require, up to a
maximum queue depth of 64.
Consult the application
documentation
on how to configure
this, as it's
different for every application.
Now, if you need higher
throughput, as opposed
to higher IOPS, there are
different recommendations.
When you need high throughput,
the best thing to do
is to increase the I/O size
to 256 kilobytes or greater.
Also, increasing the
OS read-ahead cache,
using the command line here,
will improve streaming I/O--
especially if you're
forced by the application,
for some reason, to
use small block sizes.
Please note that we intend
for the values on this slide
to change over time, as we
improve Persistent Disk.
The concepts described here
will stay true, but consult
the Persistent Disk
documentation for the latest
values.
Another performance
tip is around CPU.
It's important to note
that Google does not
require special instance type
for getting high I/O. Larger
VMs can get higher I/O by
virtue of their more CPUs.
A quick rule of thumb is
to have one CPU core free
for every 2,000 to 2,500 IOPS.
As with the last slide,
we intend this value
to change as well over time,
as make Persistent Disk better.
Please consult the documentation
for the latest value.
Like I mentioned before,
the larger a PD volume
is, the more I/O it can do.
So you never need to
create many small volumes
and stripe them together
to increase performance.
For example, one terabyte volume
will give the same performance
as 10 100-gigabyte
volumes striped together.
And because we support volumes
up to 10 terabytes in size,
you don't never need
to stripe volumes
together for space, either.
One data volume per VM is
all you should ever need.
Last performance tip.
Sometimes people
mistakenly think
there's a need to
pre-warm PD volumes.
This is not needed, as PD
volumes perform consistently
over time, and are ready
for their top performance
as soon as they're created.
Trying to pre-warm
the volumes will only
waste time and resources.
PD volumes are also consistent
relative to one another.
There's never a need to create
many volumes, test their speed,
throw away the ones
you don't like,
and keep the ones you do like.
All the volumes of the
same size and the same type
will perform the same way.
So now let's move from
performance to protection.
As you know, mistakes can
happen, bugs can happen,
and disasters will
eventually happen.
All of which can
cause you lose data
if you don't take the
proper precautions.
When using PD, please
take snapshots frequently.
This will protect you against
software and human errors that
may delete data, and
will also protect you
from physical disasters.
Because PD has
differential snapshots,
snapshot time and
storage costs will
be as efficient as possible.
Also, snapshots will never
perceptibly pause your VM,
and will not affect
your applications.
Moving away from PD
for just a second,
remember that local SSD does
not have the snapshot feature.
So make sure when
using local SSD,
if you need to protect
some of that data,
that you use some backup
mechanism supported by the OS
in application.
The last tip we have
is about moving data.
If you want to move
Persistent Disk volumes
from one zone to another
zone, the easiest thing to do
is to snapshot the PD volume
into Google Cloud Storage,
and then restore it
to the other zone.
Now, if you need to move
individual pieces of data
from a non-PD source into
a VM, into the PD volume,
you can use the
gcloud push command.
To do the reverse, and move
data from a PD volume and a VM
to a non-PD destination, you
can use the gcloud pull command.
So here's a quick summary
of what we discussed.
First, Google's block storage
is unique in its combination
of reliability, security
features, and performance
consistency.
Second, Google's
block storage options
offer a unique continuum,
with all of the block storage
options scaling performance
with volume size.
This way, the block
storage options
can be compared in an
apples to apples manner,
and decisions made simply,
mostly based on the performance
needs.
Third, all the options have
a simple price per gigabyte,
never charging extra
for I/O. You can always
be assured that each option's
complete cost is understood
up front, with no
surprises later on.
Lastly, please refer back to
this presentation for our best
practices on how to choose
between block storage types,
and how to optimize I/O. If
you follow these guidelines,
you should be able to get
consistently superb performance
at the lowest possible price.
I encourage you to try out
all of our block storage
options, especially
the two new ones
we're so excited
to announce here.
If you'd like to
follow up on any
of this presentation
for more detail,
please contact me personally,
or contact the bigger teams
using the forums listed here.
Thank you very
much for watching.